who was the author Elmore Leonard okay
yeah yeah if you watched justified
there's there's a great example of an
educated criminal because that guy you
know is the smartest cleverest again
clever a criminal thing you know but
he's he's he's smart he's clever he can
I'll talk people with his amazing
vocabulary which is better than mine
which is another thing when you're the
writer you don't have to happen know all
these words you just have to know how to
look them up do you think clever is a
negative connotation if you're called
that because it almost seems like you're
smart but not in the traditional except
a clever clever street smart kind you
know so there there might be the you
know negative connotation to that but
you know we want to write clever
dialogue we don't want to write bland
dialogue we want the dialogue to be
something where people read it and go
wow this is you know I wish I came up
with these sentences I just did a noir
class where I did a bunch of lines of
dialogue from out of the past and that
has there's this thing like a bumper
sticker actually I don't call it Pat
Patrick Ching Duncan who wrote courage
under fire and mr. Holland's Opus calls
it bumper sticker dialogue and so what
it is is it's he wrote he did some
rewrite work on a Chuck Norris movie and
he didn't get credit on screen but
everyone has the bumper sticker that
says if I want your opinion I beat it
out of you and he wrote that line and so
if you come up with those lines go go
ahead make my day you know and all those
things that'll end up on a bumper
sticker or a t-shirt you know those are
the gold we're looking for and in the
film noir class I did out of the past
just has line after line after line you
go you could engrave that on a bar of
gold and it would increase the value and
you know if we can come up those lines
that are clever that people remember
what about if there's too much conflict
sometimes they'll see that where I can
tell that someone's like okay great I
need to have conflict right away and
it's over done too much conflict is
usually or inorganic conflict it's it's
conflict that's pasted on from the
outside instead of coming from the story
and so what happens is they look at and
this is the problem
with action movies that suddenly have
car chases for no apparent reason or
fist fights or no apparent reason or
shoot us for no apparent reason it is
somebody looked into one it's getting a
little slow here we need to put in
something and they put in some they
pasted on from the outside some conflict
and that can be in a Drama to where
instead of mining the conflict
organically and looking at the
characters and going we have these two
characters here's their dispute it needs
they need to talk about this again it
could be you're avoiding talking about
avoiding that conflict ends up creating
some different conflict let's paste it
on from the outside to give us conflict
in this scene so that we can save the
good conflict for later it's like you
never want to do that you want you also
want to do is go for the for the organic
conflict for the real conflict and have
the characters deal with what's real
there instead of pasting anything on
from the outside
you